[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
so talented actor christopher jackson
received a tony nomination for his
starring role as george washington in
the mega hit musical hamilton the emmy
and grammy award winner is returning to
broadway as a special guest in the show
freestyle love supreme an improvised
hip-hop show that with the audience they
contribute words to stories and they
turned into songs and rhymes check it
out
[Music]
that's jackson performing during the
2019 run it was filmed in a documentary
we are freestyle love supreme he is a
founding member of the group which
started 17 years ago with hamilton
co-creator lin-manuel miranda evans how
about that
and last week freestyle love supreme won
a special tony award chris jackson is
joining us right now good morning chris
how are you doing good morning
that's exhausting man wow that's a lot
of stuff do you look at that and go god
that guy's good no i look at that and
and think what a life i've i've been
fortunate to have yeah and you're just
getting started sure um so
what does it feel like to be back on
broadway it's um it is amazing it's
there's there's only one place there's
only one broadway in the entire world
it's why i came to new york so walking
down the street seeing people walking to
theaters going out on that stage seeing
an audience that's so thirsty to have
that kind of communal experience
once again it's it's incredible yeah
some people said they thought it would
be intimidating or it would be
um they were a little nervous getting
back on stage did you feel any of that
the beautiful part about about freestyle
of supreme is that you absorb whatever
the audience is coming in with you know
i
i've been doing this long enough to
stood on stage
throughout the course of some you know
rather
large global events things that we were
all thinking about
we take that and we use it how do you
what do you mean you absorb it how does
it work exactly if an audience comes in
the door and they're hype
that feeds us if they come in and
they're a little tentative we know we
have to go out and get them we have to
like really reach out energy wise
looking for things that's going to pick
the audience that's going to get the
reaction and then we can kind of build
off of that but they're giving you words
and phrases and ideas absolutely work
the story with that yes no words like
i've been a couple times somebody said
avocado somebody said murder on broadway
somebody said flying on a plane just
three random things and you guys have to
figure out a way on the spot to tell to
make all that makes sense and you do
words rhyme
words rhyming you throw it's right you
throw music behind it a lot of what we
do is like jazz you have a form
but then you have you you're able to
improvise
and get out what you're feeling and get
out what the audience wants to hear it's
it's it's a neat little it's a neat
little little show yeah for those who
aren't familiar with the art of a
freestyle that's literally nate you are
familiar a little bit yeah a little
something but
you have to go off the top of your head
yeah sometimes zombie acapella and
you're literally pulling words not only
from the crowd but coming up with stuff
from yourself absolutely absolutely i
mean there there are there are they're
all different types of just like with
jazz there's all different instruments
there's all different
trains of thought there's all kinds of
different techniques rhyming wise
but more importantly the the end result
is is that you're trying to either tell
a story or you're trying to like you
know uh just engage with other artists
in real time it's it's it's it's an
exciting kind of thing it takes it takes
a lot of practice it takes a lot of work
it takes a lot of energy and effort
sometimes but you know it's it's
it's music yesterday we got very
exciting news from sarah jessica parker
who said that you're going to be part of
the i was very excited to hear the sex
and the city reboot yes like you don't
have enough to do bulls in it
you've got two kids that you adore
you're living you're working tell us
about sex in the city what are you going
to be can you tell us what you're going
to be doing i'm playing a character
herbert wexley who is uh named yeah yeah
yeah he is
the husband to the inaudible uh
nicole lori parker oh
nice so i
mar
the the way that that michael patrick
king brings male character to support
the stories of you know of these amazing
dynamic women uh it's a really good
position to sit one to see how an
incredible show is made
and the the camaraderie that already
exists in that cast and they've
enveloped new uh
characters into the show it's been
really it's it's it's been a night
because i loved watching the show when
it was on sort of in the original run me
too i kind of feel like i'm a fly on the
wall watching all how all of this magic
gets made i i think it probably it's
going to be a real fun season i'm really
so you've got the sex and the city
reboot you've got left off spring
bowling at sixth season premiering
tonight i know eight and nine hey
there's a method to our madness that's
that right we're gonna say that at the
end
no but i appreciate the plug i
appreciate it of all the different um
venues that you do
which do you prefer because there's
something different about being on stage
something different about taping a tv
show something different about
uh being on broadway sure um do you have
a preference i have i prefer whatever it
is i get to do whatever new thing that
that's in front of me um i i came into
knowing who what a the idea of a
renaissance artist is the idea of being
able to do as many things as possible as
many outlets as i can have to to be
creative uh it's not just about getting
up in front of people for me it's it's
about having an experience and and then
taking one experience and then bringing
it to another one and bring it to
another one all of these different
disciplines
uh are very difficult to get good at and
so the more that you do them the more
you understand that particular thing and
then you get to i i've been fortunate to
be able to shift over and use to
incorporate that into into other things
so the thing i like about broadway is
the reaction is immediate sure you get
the audience and sometimes there's a
cranky yankee just sitting there
refusing to engage oh yeah there's
another time you can just really feel
you have the crowd from the moment you
step out on this sure you know i think
that you know like i i distinctly
remember you know in the thousands of
shows that i've done but i remember
seeing you know people in the third row
of hamilton who were knocked all the way
out just to sleep
within like the first 10 minutes deep
sleep and that doesn't throw you no
because you know what you never know
what that person is going through that
person could be an aircraft
air traffic controller and not be able
to sleep but they get there and they're
around all these people and they came to
go to sleep you know what it is
they bought the nap they bought that
ticket right so they have earned the
right
chris
you are one of the most gifted talented
men in the business yeah one of the most
versatile versatile talents thank you so
much for joining us yes chris
freestyle love supreme is back on
broadway tonight at the booth theater
and you can watch season six of the
premiere of bull tonight where where is
that 9th central where right here on cbs
viacom cbs streaming service paramount
plus that's for sure we will be right
back